et tout de suite nous retrouvons le
groupe au bonheur des dames et leurs
chansons les filles
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
je suis sorti avec hélène vincent
peillon s'est assis quand je lui ai dit
que je l'aimais
elle m'a dit qu'elle même est aussi le
lendemain juive hydrophones fini
m
moitié des bateaux je suis sorti avec
monique au cinéma on est allé au moment
le plus tragique elle mabrier de
l'embrasser et comme je suis une fille
pratique je ne me suis pas fait prier
[Musique]
partant
je vais me
[Musique]
e
oh
je suis sorti avec marcel il est sorti
avec marseille mais rigolo ce paul ghézi
l'esprit quand je suis sorti avec
darrell il sortait avec darren je suis
sorti avec qui luttent il est sorti avec
et le mettront ces rencontres il habite
tout près de sarcelles ans alors je les
raccompagner dans son hlm
il me dit j'aime pas les [ __ ]
dans ma peau
je suis sorti avec karim ne m'a rien
demandé
elle est si les où celle-ci féminin et
j'aime c'est vos yeux étonnés
[Musique]
j aimerais tu m'as dit m
à
je pourrais
nos péchés
[Musique]
m